(upbeat music)
(door clanks)
- 3,089.
(mumbles)
4,000.
4,001.
Ain't nobody getting
my butt up in here.
4,007.
Ain't nobody getting my butt.
Not me.
Tell me, you wanna go to
jail or you wanna go home?
(snoring)
- Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike.
You okay?
- Where are we at?
- Well, listen,
Carrie drugged you,
tried to have sex with you,
and, oh, they think we
committed armed robbery
so we're in jail.
- I don't like you.
- No, you like me.
- Mm-mmm.
- Come on, come on,
take it to hole.
(yells) What a shot!
You are an athlete,
she is an athlete.
- Excuse me, Mister Policeman,
what are you watching?
- The Tulsa Shock-Phoenix
Mercury game.
- Oh, for real, who's winning?
- Mercury took it,
16, 15.
- 15, 16?
Damn!
They was balling!
Shoot it.
- Quit it with that shit man.
See, that's your problem Cam.
You always playing.
You walk up and down the
street all day playing.
Stop playing!
- If they didn't leave the car,
this would've never happened.
- They're the ones that left
the car.
- What?
- And y'all are the ones
that made them think
we committed armed robbery.
- Man, I lost my daddy's watch
while you tried to
get your dick wet.
- It wasn't no trying Cam.
Splash.
- Shut up man, you
can't even swim.
- I know how to swim!
- You can't swim--
I can swim in
something this big.
(all arguing)
- Shut the fuck up man!
- He talking to you,
he ain't talking to me.
- I'm talking to all y'all.
- He ain't talking to me.
(mumbling)
- Let me break this
down for y'all.
All I've done all day
is try to help y'all.
We got robbed by a
guy that keeps talking
about sucking dick today.
How do you think
that makes me feel?
- Hey!
Pu-Tang Clan, let's
keep it down, all right?
- Hey, who the fuck you
calling Pu-Tang Clan?
- Hey!
Guys, I have a gun, okay?
And an evidence
locker full of cocaine
so I'm gonna make
it look like y'all
did a bunch of blow if
you don't knock it off!
- So I'll sit down.
(all agreeing)
- Lookin' like John Candy.
(phone rings)
- Hello?
Really?
Are you sure?
This has happened
Again?
You know that
Well Dorm Boys, Dorm
Room Entertainment,
Dorm Door Door Door Heads,
ah, free to go.
Free to go, that's my bad.
Oh boy.
My apologies from me
and the police
department all together
so-
- Wait, wait, wait.
What happened?
- Turns out it was a white guy,
this chick was like,
"No, it was a bunch
of black people, a
bunch of black people."
So, it happens all
the time, honestly,
so big mistake.
That's my bad.
It happens all the time guys.
So, you see the confusion?
Ciao.
- No.
See ya.
Okay, so sorry about all that.
- By the way, it's Dormtainment.
- No.
(door slams)
Thank you so much, boss.
- I mean, Dorm
Entertainment is cool,
I mean, it's cool
(drowned out by door creaking)
- Sir, can I be honest with you?
Can I be honest with you?
I split a check
between six other guys.
Hello?
Okay,
here's the problem,
the goddamn car is
at a goddamn tow yard
and they tacked on
another $350 bucks.
- (smacks lips) Come on man.
(upbeat music)
- This is so Pornhub.
- See that's the girl from
the check cashing store
right there.
- Hey, um...
Did you call the cops on us?
- I did, but only because
I had to see you again.
This is special.
This is something.
- You're really weird.
- I'll give you guys
a ride to the tow yard
and pay to get your car out.
(all agreeing)
(purrs)
- God, I'm Kim and you
guys are my Kanyes,
let's do this.
(upbeat music)
- [Cam] Yo Mike, man,
did you see these pictures
that you are on IG?
They're not good bro.
It's not good, look at this.
- [Mike] Come on, man,
yo, my girl is gonna kill me.
Rome, is your fault man.
- [Rome] It ain't my fault,
Mike, shut yo ass up.
- [Girl] Ooh, the Gatorade
dry-hump pic's on Insta?
(gasps) Those were cool,
I mean, I would've done
more but they were so cool.
I would've liked it a
million times if I could've.
(upbeat music)